but now let's talk about these statues
man so these these statues get torn down
in canada
and uh one of them was queen elizabeth
ii that that threw you for a loop
earlier right you were like
surely certainly it's the first right i
was like not a second right like
you know what do you think queen
elizabeth ii does is she some vestige of
colonialism like
what has the british empire done under
her reign like it's massively contracted
actually if you think but uh did you
guys hear about the vandalism of the
george floyd statue
i think it was in new york they're
saying it's a hate crime it may be a
hate crime
think about this insane double standard
so i'll i'll pause real quick and just
do a throwback to you know jankuger's
tweet about conservatives or whatever
whatever faction the right is losing the
culture war
i gotta tell you if these leftists can
go down and tear down statues
with impunity and they do and in
philadelphia when they tried to tear
down christopher columbus
a bunch of dudes showed up with bats and
crow bars
and fended off this attack so the city
intervened and took the statue down
and then george floyd gets statues look
i get it man we don't like the guy died
it's tragic story for sure
but they're building statues and
painting murals this guy and if somebody
vandalize it it's a hate crime
all right now that's insane with a
lengthy criminal record
who went up to a pregnant woman and put
a gun on the pregnant woman's stomach
who was trading counterfeit bills and
was likely
at a lethal amount of methamphetamines
at the time of death this is who they
want to act as if
should be you know given a saint-level
platform on the democratic i've got to
correct you on that one charlie we don't
know if the meth
in his system was lethal but we do know
the fentanyl likely was
i will stand happily corrected of which
deadly substance he was actually
driving he was behind the wheel of a car
high on fentanyl
had a meatball in his mouth that he spit
out in the back seat
and he's got statues but it makes sense
why they
it makes sense why they give him a
statue though is because
they need to keep the lie going is that
kind of the current
la the current power structure is
basically organized around this event
and if they ever give an inch and this
is one of the reasons why the left is
successful is that they they will never
give an inch to us
this is something we can learn so going
back to talking about
teaching young people ian who made an
amazing point he's a guy who's behind
the wheel of a car
under the influence he was chewing on a
speed ball meth and fentanyl combined
and good reason to stop this guy i mean
we don't like you people kill kids when
you crash into cars and everything
just imagine 100 years from now though
that statement
would it persist we hope so we hope that
you listening now 100 years going
through the historical archives are like
ian crossland made the famous point
about how this guy has statues in his
honor and this is what you know
led to this moment however history is
written by the victors
if these people destroying statues win
if the people indoctrinating children
win and and jenkiner is right and in a
hundred years they're not going to say
what you said ian well i'm changing my
name to victor dude they're going to say
there you go history is written by the
victory call yourself without victory
no they're going to write the history is
going to say that george floyd wouldn't
it was an innocent man
who was wrongly targeted they're gonna
remove the counterfeit bill
they're gonna slowly over time the
pictures of chauvin will incorporate
devil horns and he'll get bigger and
bigger and
floyd will get smaller and smaller even
though floyd was huge and chauvin was
small
history is written by the victor so in
100 years they'll say this
poor innocent man who was oppressed
under a system of white sis
heteronormative patriarchy
was brutally beaten and murdered by
neo-nazis
and we honor his memory because and
there's gonna and the pictures and the
images that will come out
will show him on the ground like
reaching up and people standing around
like gasping
it's like i understand it was a tragedy
man i understand that we don't want this
guy to die like i don't want to see
anybody hurt i don't see anybody die
but you know they're going to lie about
it as they already are and the lies will
get worse
and it's also how did he die the jury
decided it died because of chauvin's
actions and again this came at a moment
that they needed it to happen though
this happened right before an election
when everyone was locked down there was
a lot of pent-up energy there were no
public sporting events no gymnasiums no
social settings people were lacking of
purpose
and they needed an excuse to try to
reinvigorate the racial reckoning of how
awful we are right before
donald trump's election and so it just
so happened that because of a
constellation of these events
they got what they needed and they being
the people who
capitalized on a single incident for a
broader power grab
i wonder if young people are going to
recognize you know young people who are
like
maybe 13 year old today 13 year olds
today you know they're not really paying
attention to this stuff
are they going to recognize the sheer
insanity of having a pandemic and a
national and even global lockdown but
allowing protests
whether are they gonna in their twenties
when they're voting are they gonna be
like it was really strange they did that
or
they completely forget because it will
be scrubbed from the narrative
yeah i mean it depends i mean depends on
what the world looks like in seven years
which is largely why we're having this
conversation it depends whether or not
we're gonna be allowed to have these
kind of conversations
on these sort of platforms which remains
to be seen i mean
kind of the last the last hope we have
is the capacity to have dialogue
and that's the only way that people like
that are ever going to find out the
truth and
that's why shows like this are doing
very well and that's why services like
rumble
are doing as well as they're doing which
is a very serious competitor
competitor to youtube and i want to talk
about big tech because i think it's
really interesting but
a 13 year old to think it's perfectly
normal unless
presented with the alternative viewpoint
that there's
there's a pressure happening with big
tech though and uh we
we're talking about this yesterday you
don't need to ban people that that's the
stupid move
right if you ban someone like crowder it
sends a man
you drop a giant stone in the middle of
a leg and ripples come out it would be
like dropping a bus
big splash everybody sees it so how how
do you do it well you put a pressure on
content you
you stop promoting it you start
suppressing it you stop giving out
notifications
you give a strike here and then you stop
and then you wait two months and boom
another strike so now you're stacking
them up
my concern is we've we've heard that
youtube for instance is
is now applying age restrictions on tons
of videos
so here's what happens people who are
effective at communicating with the
younger generation will start seeing age
restrictions
and that won't completely ban the
content and smart savvy young people
will find a way around it
but it will dramatically reduce the
reach
that pressure over a long enough period
of time means your speech
is stamped out that that's exactly right
i mean we're dealing with this with
youtube right now
where i mean we have a massive decrease
in viewers we were talking about this
earlier
viewers in live stream uh content but i
i think it even goes beyond that
i think that there's a demonetization
strategy and i also think there's a
shadow band strategy
they don't deem you front page worthy
they don't even if people have the
the bell and subscribe they won't get
the push notification on the phone we go
through all i mean you go through the
same sort of thing all the time
and i mean we were getting 70 000 live
viewers right near the election we're
now down like 500 600 a day
and so that kind of you could say what
you want but that kind of fractional
election season i i think a lot of that
is due to seventy thousand to five
hundred is that's a lot
that is that that is yeah for for us it
was like
we probably lost around half we we were
averaging maybe like 65k
live now we do you know 30 sometimes 40.
the for you it sounds definitely like
suppression well it's also because the
crawlers are seeing how often i'm
mentioning their competitor rumble.com
which i think actually is going to be
a sizable and serious competitor to the
youtube death star
one thing for sure that people should be
worried about and it's also a potential
way to camouflage censorship is
we had an election year views were
through the roof plus everyone was
locked down so you're locked down it's
election year
naturally views are through the roof now
the election year is over
a lot of people are feeling like well my
views are going to go down right
but some a lot of leftist channels
aren't having that so maybe you know
makes a point yeah when you control the
cultural institutions and you can cheat
and uh you know maybe and suppress
information maybe then you'll actually
win because you're not letting people
be free to choose their own information
but there's there was a meme from 4chan
they said any sufficiently fr uh
oh any social media network that is
sufficiently free speech will inevitably
inevitably become right wing or our
unmoderated platform will inevitably
become right-wing
because leftist ideas only exist with
with uh censorship and suppression
i don't know i mean you know twitter
thought of itself as a free speech
platform so did
so did facebook they all they all
thought they started that way and then
they just felt this inexorable pressure
the combination of external activists
and
and internal employee pressure because
of who they were hiring
and even and have gotten to the
censorious place they're in
um i think it's just and also the right
wing competitors are relative i mean
other than rumble which is doing well
but i think
um you know a lot of the right-wing
twitter competitors so far have failed
miserably i think would is a fair
description
well uh i i i agree to an extent
it seems like parlor would have actually
taken off right well
save for you know the massive collective
anti-trust action that happened against
them
you know it was funny i was actually i
was doing a panel in uh florida with
like a big tech
lobbyist type and uh he was just we
we asked him about like this power thing
he's just like well it was january 6 and
i'm like i'm sorry is there a january 6
exception of the annie trust laws like
why are you does this something
collaborate to knock out competitors
that wasn't even true
yeah yeah parlor was cooperating and
like sending warnings to the fbi
and facebook had way more of the content
that they were supposedly objecting to
they did that to minds i don't i don't
know how public that is i think
it was mentioned oh yeah vice wrote
about it they tried making claims that
minds.com which ian is a co-founder uh
that it was somehow harboring the far
right when it was like six accounts
that was like exactly because when you
when you go the route of trying not to
censor people
people will take advantage of it and
they'll make like 50 accounts and then
spam
egregious things and then if you if you
say i'm not going to censor you they're
like that's like a green light to say
the worst things you can sometimes just
for whatever reason get a reaction to
make money to to change people's minds i
don't know so
censorship is extremely valuable but i
just have to be super careful with it
but in that instance with mines it was
like there were six accounts that had
like no posts but posted like a banner
image of some far-right symbol
and then vice is like minds becomes the
new haven for the far
right it's like just objectively not
true we just need to put all these
journalists out of a job right like the
simple thing to do here is just like
we get we get the laws we need in terms
of like non-discrimination like making
essentially you have a right to use
these accounts
florida tried to do it didn't get there
um but
we do that and all of a sudden i want to
make life easier in some sense for jack
dorsey mark zuckerberg i want them to be
able to look at these activists and be
like
i'm sorry if we did what you want we
would get sued and we'd lose so we're
not going to do what you want
because like you know if you had a
racist clientele at a hotel that was
like i don't want you to serve black
people they'd be like
well one you're a racist so we're not
going to pay attention to you but to
even if we did we'd we'd be breaking the
law
so we're not going to right you can't
you can't do you can't do that so that's
that's the position i want the social
media companies to be in yeah but they
don't want to be in those positions but
uh they they're ideologically driven i
mean
you look at jack dorsey he's a huge
activist putting money
he put a bunch of money into like woke
programs he does a bunch of activism in
africa which that i don't know a whole
lot about but i'm not saying his
activism is bad but the man is
ideologically driven
you heard what he said uh when i when i
talked to him this gets brought up a lot
but here we go again when i was on the
joe rogan podcast
and he said you know when it comes to
misgendering policy there's
there's people that we're concerned
about and they they could take their own
lives and so we're very worried and
trying to protect them and it's like i
understand that for sure but there are a
lot of people who are at risk for taking
their own lives and you're not
protecting them
i specifically mentioned body dysmorphia
people who want to remove their hands
for instance
that's not part of their policy it's
purely politically
ideologically driven now you you
mentioned laws
will and i want to i want to say this
too i think a lot of conservatives
need to recognize who was it breitbart
who said politics is downstream from
culture
yeah brilliant and even with that being
known to many conservatives or just
it's not even just conservatives there's
many disaffected liberals like these
these teachers in loudoun county
people like me for instance it's not
about the laws
the laws you know i think back to
when we had certain social cohesion in
some areas it maybe maybe it wasn't
a lot of people might romanticize the
past it was probably bad in a lot of
ways for a lot of reasons
the law's morality laws for instance or
obscenity laws didn't make
people not want to swear george carlin
decided to swear anyway and he got
arrested for because
i'm going to do it it was that there was
social enforcement
so yeah i mean i think the way to think
about it is there's feedback going both
ways some laws are
really more shaped by culture than vice
versa and some laws make it possible for
people to shape culture or prevent them
from using it so the reason i focus so
heavily on big tech issues and why it's
so central to me is because i see it as
kind of a keystone issue for the right
if we lose on big tech we're going to
lose everywhere else because
the cadet companies are going to shape
discourse and culture in such a way
that we can't compete and are going to
knock out all our best influencers
knock out all our people who are
persuasive young people et cetera et
cetera et cetera so
like they're coming after you bro right
on tech
oh they're but but the things the things
i see about you are really interesting i
go on reddit
and they have all the memes about you
and they're a lot of them they're
they're actually they're actually pretty
funny
but that's powerful they're pretty funny
the bench ones are really funny
uh and it was impressive because for a
while the meme was the left can't mean
and then i think they started to figure
out they were losing and one of the
things that helped drive
trump's victory i went to i went to
dozens of trump rallies in 2015 and 16.
i met tons of young people who told me
culture war culture world
the older guys were like trade trade
trade younger guys were like free speech
culture war feminism so then i see these
memes popping up on reddit it's like
you go on reddit it's nothing but
propaganda it's insane
and boy do they not like you but they
have to do it you know why
they need to poison the well when a
turning point event shows up and i'm and
i'm not
saying i've not actually ever been to
one of your events or anything like that
i'm just saying i understand you guys
engage in political rhetoric
so the well is poisoned for young people
when they see
a meme saying charlie kirk is dumb or
something
then what you get are these young high
school kids
will see an event coming to town and
they'll be more easily told not to go
because they want to be cool or fit in
yeah and i think there's a limitation on
that obviously and
i mean like no one's above mockery right
we're not going to take ourselves too
seriously i mean everyone said really
dumb things including me i could
spend about four and a half hours on
that if we had that um
and so an entire list of things i could
say that were dumb
but i think look hopefully a wise person
wants to be corrected
and there's obvi the limitation on it
though is i think that in those kind of
reddit 4chan circles those people that
do those things
they try to mock the people they see
that are actually organizing something
substantial
and so i mean i take it hopefully as
well and stride as one can and also i
just don't look at that stuff i've
deleted all social media off my phone i
don't have twitter on facebook don't
have any of that
and so people are like oh you're
trending on twitter i'm like oh really
it feels the same as when i wasn't
trending
right i think more clearly i read more
books and
post radio and do podcasting uh but i
would say it's it's not about us
necessarily your your health or anything
no no for sure but like i just
go just one quick side note on the jack
dorsey thing is that if all of a sudden
the social media companies are
existing to be like the therapist of the
entire like transgender community
that that is an incredibly that is not
what you exist to do at all like while
people are going to hurt themselves like
well
you know that's obviously not what we
don't want people to have happen but
under that excuse you're just going to
basically abolish every single
meaningful point of criticism is it
isn't it true that cops commit suicide
at high rates
of course yeah we gotta we gotta have a
special rule on twitter saying you can't
disparage police
oh yeah it's gotta ha it's gotta you
know i mean if you're taking that much
editorial responsibility then take
editorial responsibility and like just
forego your section 230 liability and
eat the defamation
and it's just pandering to activists
right and so kind of just going back to
this whole idea
of kind of where the left-wing activist
energy is going
um it's been very interesting to track
over the last six or seven months of
kind of what they're focusing on and
what they're doing
um and i think that there is a there's a
tension point that's brewing
of they're they're not sure really when
to draw the line of when they're like oh
no no we
actually shouldn't cancel every single
white person in the world
and and they haven't said that out loud
yet but you're starting to see that
reflected in some of their
opinion articles and in some of the more
left-wing podcasting world
they're all of a sudden starting to
retreat a little bit from there because
there is a fear that
kind of the french revolution guillotine
is going to come for them too i mean rob
spierer was murdered by his own
followers and they applauded for 10
minutes
that did was nuts maximilian rob speer
yeah
let me tell you when i was at occupy
wall street there was a guy down there
who told everyone his dream was to be
robespierre
and then when people would be able to
get his head cut off yes his jaw blown
off
they blew his jaw off and let him sit
there for like two days and yeah in pain
and and there there were people down
there and one guy said that was his
dream and when people were like
he was killed by his own followers he
was like man wouldn't that be great
like they they're it's these these are
people who are actively organizing
i'm not gonna say every single one of
them is insane some of them are just
dumb some of them are idealistic and
utopian
and some of them are outright
sociopathic thinking like wow how cool
would that be to have my jaw blown off
and then be guillotined
by my own followers genuinely people and
so so the the arc of all these things
the french revolution's super
instructive for a variety of different
reasons because
the abolition of private property the
the destruction of time right they got
rid of the old agrarian calendar they
put in a 10-day calendar
the deletion metric time right exactly
the deletion of um
of their history um very much inspired
by rousseau
is but the ark tells us where this leads
and this is really
the desire of the rulers of our country
which is you will get an autocrat it's
just
this sort of manufactured chaos the
blood in the streets
the french revolution types that kill
tens of thousands of people is yeah then
you're going to get a napoleon
that that is what will happen and
zuckerberg and bezos i think they want
to be part of that oligarchy
that will rule aft in the next chapter
so we're kind of in this
revolutionary period so we're ever going
to go to republican small our re
style government or towards autocracy i
think it's autocracy
um but the night is always darker for
the dawn and just because these people
i i think we're currently in uh some
form of uh
maybe not destrocracy is the right word
maybe oligopoly yeah i agree completely
i think there was a document it's been a
while but during occupy wall street
there was a document circulated from
citigroup
that said that the united states is not
a democracy it is an oligopoly or
something like that
or uh yeah that's that effect
effectively
the us government laws are written by
the wealthy
that public opinion has very little
impact at all and there were other
studies saying basically the same thing
can i say one thing about occupy so i
went to zuccotti park too and i was told
because i was a conservative
in high school to hate those people and
now i go back to some of your footage
and the footage that's there and i find
very little i disagree with
out of the main components of the
criticism of occupy wall street
such as you have a small group of rather
reckless people and financial
institutions that made highly
levered risk they got bailed out by
taxpayers meanwhile middle class incomes
go down and we're you know re-domiciling
all of our meaningful manufacturing
overseas
and i i think that there's a game being
played here and identity politics is the
piece on the table
where there could be a bipartisan
reckoning against bezos the only thing
we can agree with the other side on is
this racist stuff
he's like everyone's a racist that's the
only that's the only thing that's
preventing
a 90 type revolution against bezos after
we wrapped up our our
our show with steve bannon you know he's
standing up and getting ready to walk
out and i was like steve i mean it
if you went down there to occupy wall
street on day one it would have been
it would have been an entirely different
timeline there were no
prominent right-wing personalities
coming down to guide that massive
anger at the corrupt financial
institutions in the government so what
happened was
there were conservatives there were
libertarians there were leftists there
was regular people
i met luke ridkowski of we are change
who is like an anarcho-capitalist
he's all about that right-wing
libertarianism i met him down there
and we agreed on on basically everything
we weren't
concerned about tax policy when we're
looking at corrupt government
but there were no strong prominent
right-wing personalities in fact
when it came to fox news it was
disparaging the only disagreement i'll
give you
on that is that the movement was not
ready for this nine years ago the
conservative movement yeah we had a
muscle memory
and we had a configuration to defend
massive financial institutions no matter
what we were
we were on team corporate right so like
team right was team corporate that was
the conservative movement i grew up in
right
we were the party of saying you know
what it's a good thing that mitt romney
is a car elevator
and he says the trees are the right
height and he puts a dog on his car and
we like it and bain capital is awesome
and we love china and plastic from china
and from wuhan is the greatest thing
ever and if you disagree with me you're
a socialist
that that was how we were trained to
debate in 2012 13 and 14
and trump was awesome at all of a sudden
challenging all these orthodoxies so the
only disagreement i have and you might
be right bannon could have changed some
of that i don't disagree with you on
that though
i just don't think the movement was
ready for it i think we're ready for it
now
i think that we're ready for it more
than ever like we want to crush these
corporations now
so here's the here's here's the issue
man you know when we have someone like
vosh on the show who's this prominent
you know socialist youtuber
when i mentioned occupy wall street and
things like that he goes i was i was a
teenager i remember that
i was i i don't know what happened and i
don't blame him this is this is one of
the biggest challenges with with talking
to young people and getting
getting them active if if dude's 16
years old and occupy wall street's
happening of course he's not paying
attention to the financial collapse
that was three years prior so he's a
little kid and he doesn't know about
what joe biden is doing
now you get a bunch of people who are 18
years old and 20 years old
and they're going to vote and they're
being told by the clowns on tv to vote
for joe biden
and you go to them and say his brother's
deals with in iraq
occupy wall street the financial
collapse their defense of big
capital and i don't remember any of that
i have no idea that's what they say
yeah i mean i guess part of it is
attributable to age right
um but i will say though and i just want
to reinforce this point
the the masters of the universe for lack
of a better term the ruling
class as angela codovilla would call
them which is a perfect term
they know that race is the perfect
distraction
issue there would be a legitimate
economic revolution
if we could put crt to bed and it would
be a good thing for our country
and i'm not saying we need to
nationalize the airlines or like
confiscate goldman sachs's offices
what i am saying though is that there is
a legitimate
there's a cartel that exists that makes
normal people's
livelihood more difficult to thrive and
to flourish the family is harder than
ever to create and have lots of children
and there's a bipartisan agreement on
that thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you